[Musique]
vous souhaitez avoir un truc je tairai
mounir un stade gilbert aubry
les pompiers ou le samu ses actes a dit
j'ai appris qu'ils appellent le samu ou
les bouviers et voilà c'est tout moi ça
je suis incapable de faire le moindre
choix repas dhabi pour les sorties tapas
dhabi pour l'heure jamais d'avis c'est
vrai que la langue est une grosse merde
t'as vu c'est tout le mieux c'est qu'on
leur trouve un mec un mais je vais
m'intéresser qui suis vieille et je suis
tapé fort nantais bat ap qu'est ce que
devrait dire jouer alors je vais je
tapais quand tu ne trouves je te trouve
comme tu veux c'est en réponse à ces la
formule mais la chaudière photomaton
seul
diomandé france el aouel célibataire et
bah ouais je sais pas qui a bu leux
d'accord qu'en fait tu vas tu bois tu
manges les restes d'un labrador ou
bonsoir momo tu lui dis pas que j'ai un
petit problème un finish je pense qu'il
va vite s'apercevoir que ton petit pour
maps earth est en train madame vous avez
fait votre choix la trilogie trigger à
la voix l'appareil j'ai besoin de parler
du lobby my wife j'aimais une celle de
mon âge de toute ma vie et autre choc de
cette journée c'est que j'ai bien
réfléchi là pour la date du mariage
le 12 juillet le 12 juillet là on peut
plus reculer
on parle de deux mecs super à qui tu vas
faire du mal choisi
kaba attendre d'être devant le maire
pour prendre sa décision
si tu aimes les abats on va très très
bien sûr ton truc j'aime aussi les
fresques même
[Musique]